bonsoir nouvelle semaine pour le journal
de la rédaction nous sommes le lundi 29
septembre invité aujourd'hui fois de
madec directeur de l'esat de la marsa 20
et qui accueille des adultes en
situation de handicap pour les aider sur
le marché du travail
il vient de recevoir l'ordre national du
mérite vous voyez des images de la
cérémonie avec l'ancien ministre benoît
hamon qui étaient présents des habitants
qui portent ensemble un projet pour se
loger un avantage sur les plans
écologique et économique la ville de la
verrière propose de développer l'idée
sur des terrains situés près de la gare
et puis retour sur le festival twenty
fort succès mitigé le public ne s'est
pas déplacé en nombre pour cette
première au vélodrome nationale et ce
malgré une affiche exceptionnelle
le sénat est renouvelé par moitié à
l'occasion d'élections qui sont qui se
sont déroulés à dimanche au scrutin
universel indirect seul les grands
électeurs élus ou conseillers municipaux
en majorité mais aussi des conseillers
généraux régionaux députés et qui
étaient invités à désigner les sénateurs
ce renouvellement ne concernait donc pas
l'ile-de-france le sénat a été pendant
trois ans à gauche il bascule maintenant
à nouveau à droite
mercredi il sera question d'élire un
nouveau président parmi les postulants
l'ancien président du sénat justement
ancien maire de rambouillet gérard
larcher catherine tasca sénatrice
socialiste élu depuis à 2004 réagi au
basculement du sénat à droite
nous allons perdu la majorité que nous
avions gagné en 2011
ceci dit ça n'est pas une surprise
complète pour moi si vous voulez ce qui
a fait la difficulté de la majorité de
gauche au sénat
c'est l'absence de d'unités l'absence de
travail en commun des différentes
composantes de la gauche sur la manière
d'aborder les textes les sujets de débat
je pense que ça ne changera pas
profondément les les choses autant que
je vous le savez le en cas de non vote
d'un texte celui-ci continue son chemin
et est au bout du chemin l'assemblée
nationale peut avoir le dernier mot
ça dépendra beaucoup de la manière dont
la nouvelle présidence du sénat concevra
son rôle il y à la modération naturelles
du sénat
les ya aussi visiblement une volonté de
d'incarner une opposition et nos
positions très fermes au gouvernement et
si notre secteur n'était pas concerné
directement par cette élection
sénatoriale comment réagissez-vous ce
matin à l'annoncé de cette nouvelle
défaite de la gauche au pouvoir le sénat
va-t-il avoir une influence sur la
politique actuellement menée par le
gouvernement voici vos réponses au micro
de patrick jacques de dixmude
je crois que c'est l'assemblée nationale
qui prime avant tout donc non je pense
pas que ça va changer grand chose
c'est l'anti râler les lois mais ça
changera pas le résultat final ça n'a
pas trop d'importance quand même ils
disent non pour certaines réformes il
perd près se repassent à l'assemblée
nationale pour moi la france est devenue
une république bananière en fait
forcément ça va être un peu plus
difficile de faire passer les lois du
premier coup calé sénat passe à droite
ou à gauche afin de rien façon à gauche
et droite sont tous ensemble c'est céder
même personne et que tu suis normalement
c'est toujours en france il vaut mieux
que déjà les voir son voeu partagé
c'est un mystère ce sont la droite la
gauche pour l'instant apprendre grand
chose qui a changé
donc ils ont quitté la politique et vous
allez le découvrir dans un instant ce
reportage il vient de devenir chevalier
de l'ordre national du mérite fois de
mada qu'est donc l'invité ce soir
bienvenue en plateau merci merci d'être
venus ce soir directeur de l'esat de la
marsa 20 attrape depuis 2012 les
attaques oeil des adultes en situation
de handicap les formes à différents
métiers dans des secteurs divers
comme la restauration l'accueil la
blanchisserie les espaces verts le
service aux entreprises
nous allons revenir sur cette cérémonie
de remise de votre distinction c'était
vendredi en présence de benoît hamon
vous l'avez aperçu tout juste heureux
devenu et député de la 11e
circonscription musique fait chevalier
quad madec et directeur de l'esab de la
marsa 22 puis 2012
l'établissement reçoit 200 personnes en
situation de handicap acquis la
structure propose une formation et un
travail dans différents métiers en 2013
à l'établissement difficultés
financières connaît un retour à
l'équilibré en 2014 ce sont 250
entreprises partenaires alors y at il
une méthode fois de madec
c'est d'abord le être sincère avec soi
même c'est le respect des autres
au niveau de ma part de mon personnel
c'est la démarche participative bien
faire pour que les personnes au mois
viennent avec le sourire et repartent
avec un grand épanouissement de
l'établissement et ça c'est notre
quotidien tous les jours on associe si
l'insertion de personnes en situation de
handicap par le travail et performance
économique
donc c'était une très belle
très belle réussite en recevant cette
médaille fois de manet qui n'oublie pas
non plus son parcours personnel
il a vécu une partie de sa vie au maroc
mais c'est en france qu'il est
accueillie après ses études
la république française qu'il honore une
double fierté un pays qui m'a offert
énormément d'opportunités que ce soit en
terme de formation que ce soir au terme
de travail alors je me dois où je me
devais
durant tout mon parcours professionnel
de partager donner aux autres et
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire que
je suis un homme
un homme
combler c'est quelqu'un qui est qui est
riche alors comme on l'a dit de
plusieurs cultures dada proches etc
et puis surtout porteur de beaucoup de
projets avec à la fois de l'audace et là
il en faut si je crois que c'est ça
l'audace et puis la compétence on signe
un et lors de cette remise de médaille
le nouveau chevalier de l'ordre du
mérite a souhaité mettre en avant les
salariés de la filière cuisine 35
personnes qui ont travaillé pendant plus
d'une semaine pour préparer le buffet et
pour paraphraser fois de madec chaque
personne compte dans l'établissement
phonevalley qu'on l'a entendu dans ce
reportage vous avez une grande fierté
d'avoir reçu cette médaille de chevalier
de l'ordre national du mérite quand
benoît hamon vous a épinglé cette
distinction
l'ancien ministre vous remets cette
distinction comme quoi vous avez pensé
vous êtes senti c'est oui combien c'est
une grande fierté et puis
déjà en novembre 2013 comme la
population comme quoi j'étais nommé
effectivement par décret pour les
prochains prêtons d'oran j'ai envie de
leur dire accrochez vous les wagons
parce que c'était un tsunami d'émotion
qui arrive et puis tout de suite on se
pose la question pourquoi moi qu'est ce
que j'ai fait et puis on a un déroulé et
c'est vrai c'est un grand honneur que la
république nous a fait
lenovo se valide et d'autres sur un
autre point qui a été évoqués dans le
reportage
vous êtes un homme de plusieurs cultures
vous êtes à la fois une culture
marocaine est aussi une culture bretonne
du maroc que vous avez cette culture
bretonne nous en dire un peu plus sur
cette double culture
et bah écoutez c'est
c'est là
le hasard de la part ou t on ce retrouve
abandonné sur cette double culture
j'ai même envie de dire que je pense que
db c'est le berbère et c'est le p proton
et c'est une richesse
qui permet à vous contenter d'avoir le
recul nécessaire de voir sa vie de bois
aussi les autres et de pouvoir apporter
le plus que ce soit sur le pont
personnel sur le programme il yal sur le
plan social sur le plan professionnel
c'est ce que j'ai essayé de faire
pendant trente ans de ma vie ici
notamment en france
sur le conditionnel et benoît hamon qui
dit de vous que vous êtes un exemple au
moment du discours avec sentiment d'être
un exemple moment sans faire d'amalgamé
on entend parler tout de même
d'extrémisme de jeunes qui ont du mal
aussi à s'insérer dans la société
d'origine diverses sont bien sûr hein je
le redis faire des amalgames surtout ça
vous avez le sentiment d'être un exemple
de montrer que je crois pas voilà la
république
il est important d fois de parler des
des ascenseurs qui arrivent et surtout
des trains ou des avions qui arrivent à
l'heure je pense pas j'ai pas la
prétention d'être l'exemple mais je
je crois qu'on la graine ils prennent ça
permet effectivement
ce
ce partage sociétale à et plus chacun
garde sa place et reste à sa place tout
temps
tout en donnant le maximum aux autres
par rapport à ce que nous avons reçues
vous avez repris vos études à 50 ans oui
j'ai repris mes études de cinq ans est
diplômé de venir voilà c'est une
aventure comme l'a dit monsieur boivin
monde donc mes enfants m'appellent le
grand étudiants a déclenché cette envie
de reprendre les études à 50 ans
remplace l'institut d'études politiques
c'est parce que j'étais intéressé par
les personnes âgées et puis j'avais près
le domaine de la gérontologie
donc j'avais fait déjà l'écho nationale
santé publique et puis le handicap je
pense que j'avais fait le tour en terme
de tout ce qui peut être connaissances
et expériences
et puis je m'intéressais beaucoup par
rapport au vieillissement des personnes
en situation de handicap et c'est ça qui
m'a amené effectivement vers le chemin
de l'école au corps à nouveau
si tu as des sciences politiques à paris
au cours de l'ag d'anthologie ces
personnes que vous accueillez les
ajustements les personnes en difficulté
en situation de handicap
qu'est ce que vous leur transmettaient
en premier qu'est ce que vous avez envie
de leur faire passer en premier
écoutez cdc des personnes à connaître un
beau jeu de passes qui me vient donner
d'abord avant de leur apprendre quelques
tapes et et nous apprennent beaucoup de
choses sur la vie de ce côté là je
je suis assez modeste 1 par rapport à ce
qu'on leur apporte c'est d'abord tout un
travail tout en avez sociale entre la
thérapeutique qu'on met en place et puis
la mise au travail
donc c'est un apprentissage selon le
rite ou sont dans la capacité selon le
choix de chacun de chaque personne
l'originalité de nos trésors c'est que
personne n'est figé dans un atelier
quelconque 1 donc ils ont la possibilité
de passer dans les différents postes de
travail sur le beau matthew liés comme
ils peuvent à changer en cours de leur
existence dans les actes d'un atelier à
l'autre c'est pour ça qu'on a mis en
place les quatre pôles d'activité que
vous avez eue libérer les âmes n'était
pas forcément en très bonne santé
lorsque vous êtes arrivé aux affaires
2013 seulement retour à l'équilibré
financier 2014 250 entreprises
partenaires on peut citer à renault par
exemple aussi parmi les grands groupes
que vous avez réussi ce tour de force
c'est à dire il faut revenir un petit
peu à l'histoire un jeu j'étais
directeur de cet établissement de 2003 à
2006 1 avant de partir en expatriation
avec handicap international sur des
programmes de l'onu et
la banque mondiale et l'union européenne
et puis après ben
quatre ans après
on a fait appel pour effectivement
revenir
sur ces établissements là donc j'ai
repris les affaires en main en 2012
il était
il était institutionnellement et
économiquement ballon quoi donc on n'a
pas le temps on reprenne d'abord notre
bâton de pèlerin c'est-à-dire tout ce
qui est prospection commerciale et puis
reprendre les outils institutionnels qui
ne sont imposés par la loi de 2002 à
2005 et j'ai eu des échos très
favorables
c'est peut-être le monde et convaincre
ses différents partenaires des
difficultés c'est d'arriver en plus mais
vous avez c'est je crois que notre
devoir ce n'est pas sur les pales
l'handicap convent mais c'est plutôt la
prestation et les entreprises y sont
sensibles à une prestation de qualité ou
délai à la réactivité et je crois que la
première chose que j'ai essayé de faire
c'est de sensibiliser le personnel par
rapport déjà à 7 à ces deux aspects la
réactivité et la qualité de la
prestation
à partir de ce moment là on a
on a quasiment refait ont refondé
complètement les pôles d'activités pour
qu'il y ait de la visibilité à
l'intérieur de la visibilité à
l'extérieur plus un travail de
prospection qui qui a été fait pour
qu'on puisse effectivement répondre aux
demandes des entreprises
c'est pour ça qu'on a développé des
activités comme les plateaux-repas
cocktails comme les et puis la
blanchisserie qui est passé de stade
artisanal un stade industriel où on est
passé de 250 kg un jour à houston
un jour donc avec les normes est
rabaissée parce que les entreprises y
sont aussi exigeants par rapport aux
normes la cuisine qui est tour haccp et
puis tout ce qui est ce parce vert on
est sur les dispositifs depuis
phytosanitaires donc ça effectivement
cessé attractives ces vendeurs
ça prouve de la qualité des prestations
que nous faisons et 2013 on a vu assez
rapidement le retour à l équilibre pour
pouvoir éponger l'équivalent de 750
mille euros de déficit en êtes-vous milk
accor gère comme je les dis vendredi
semble très prometteuse puisque parmi
nos clients on compte beaucoup
d'entreprises du cac 40 1 ce qui est
d'ailleurs extraordinaire pour le milieu
de l'handicap où nous avons thales
safran bouygues
puis on au rcd donc il ya pas mal
d'entreprises effectivement qui se voit
ni motivation aussi ça c'est vraiment
c'est très très important pour nous
parce que c'est une reconnaissance de la
qualité de la prestation et c'est une
valorisation des travailleurs de les
voir partir à la retraite heures quand
je les vois partir alors le troque ses
défenses ont détachement permanent
travailler avec les cadres manger avec
les cadres
je crois que là on a atteint le summum
de ce que j'appelle de tous mes voeux
l'inclusion sociale des personnes en
situation de handicap et à vous écouter
la remise de cette distinction la remise
de ce mérite chevalier de l'ordre
national du mérite
ça vous a motivé pour la suite c'est pas
une fin en soi ça vous a donné encore
envie d'aller encore plus loin on sent
que vous portez a vraiment perdu sur
monsieur me suis à mon compte et maro
mais c'est un signe là il me met un
petit peu la barre un peu haute
mais bon c'est dans le jeune chien c'est
dans les motivations
nous avons effectivement trois gros
projets sur lesquels
on appelait déjà commencé à travailler
c'est là l'ouverture d'une unité pour
autistes 1 avec maraîchage bio qui est
normalement doit avoir lieu sûr
magny les hameaux et puis un service
d'accompagnement à la vie sociale
et puis des appartements thérapeutiques
donc on a pas mal de perspectives
ô combien de personnes accompagnées
actuellement et puis je rectifie alors
actuellement nous sommes à 145 personnes
encadrées par 45 salariés pour dire peu
c'est une petite pme et puis donc on va
monter au crachin tôt avec les autistes
pour arriver à prendre en plus
et puis une dizaine ferme thérapie
j'apporte mon thérapeutique et puis une
dizaine pour le sbs merci beaucoup aux
fans avec directeur de l'esat de la
marsa 20 attrapé félicitations donc
façon vous êtes chevalier de l'ordre
national du mérite
merci à vous nous reprenons le cours du
journal et cette information 25 1911
c'est le nombre de voitures volées ou
dégradé en un an l'association 40
millions d'automobilistes place le
département des yvelines sur la deuxième
marche du podium un triste record battu
seulement par le rhône la lozère n'a
connu depuis juin 2013 que 531 vols ou
dégradations un projet de logements
partagés se met doucement en place à la
verrière pour le moment six familles
travaillent de concert pour créer un
espace de vie commun samedi dernier elle
a organisé un pique nique avec les
partenaires pour discuter des
différentes avancées clark en biais
tintamarre un joli jeu de mot pour
évoquer le projet d'habitat participatif
créé autour des terrains de la mare 4000
m² en tout qui pourrait accueillir une
douzaine de familles entre la rue de la
gare hissel delamare ici de mouvements
existants qui veulent des vielles
maisons qui vont être démolis par la
ville on aura quatre secteurs de
construction donc ici ici ici ici pour
construire une douzaine de maisons dont
on envisage des unités de voisinage de
trois quatre familles maximum à
l'initiative de ce projet la ville de la
verrière qui a chuté progressivement ce
terrain un appel à candidature a été
lancé pour trouver les futurs habitants
pour le moment six familles sont
impliqués dans le projet la question
centrale aujourd'hui c'est comment on
fabrique de la ville et la ville s'est
pas simplement de mettre côte à côte des
bâtiments c'est de mettre de la vie à
l'intérieur de la ville et ça c'est une
façon de concevoir autrement la ville
c'est à dire les gens s'approprient un
espace définissent ensemble des besoins
et travaille aussi sur l'usagé les
règles de vie car habitat participatif
implique que les futurs habitants
portent ensemble le projet et partage à
terme certains espaces communs le groupe
tente un marc se réunit régulièrement
pour discuter des points architecturaux
financiers et légaux pour les épauler la
ville a fait appel au cabinet de conseil
quad et à l'association labo ramdam ces
rencontres créé déjà un esprit de groupe
et une volonté de vivre ensemble
on le sent déjà rien que dans les
réunions et ce qui est déjà mis en place
on a déjà vraiment un bon contact avec
ceux qui sont là et puis ceux qui sont
pas encore là dans les attend ça sera
pareil seront bien accueillis une autre
manière de se loger et des avantages
écologiques et économiques de 20 à 30%
en dessous du prix du marché
constructivement c'est plus économique
on dépense moins en construisant un côté
de son voisin et en faisant que quatre
façades pour des maisons que de 0,8
façade pour deux maisons et or on
dépense ensuite moins d'énergie à se
chauffer parce que notre voisin qui nous
chauffe un peu aussi des places sont
encore disponibles pour intégrer ce
projet si c'est un succès la ville
pourrait renouveler ce type d'habitat
dans le quartier de garder cannes
premier jour seule ouverture ce lundi
pour la nouvelle micro crèche installée
à montigny le bretonneux la structure
qui se veut un lieu d'intégration et de
mixité accueillera à temps plein sept
enfants de 0 à 6 ans qu'ils soient
valides ou en situation de handicap un
projet mené par deux amis originaires de
saint quentin en yvelines
on est vraiment resté sur un lieu de vie
voilà un enfant qui sont handicapés ou
pas ou peu
peut que jouer peut s'épanouir on a
juste fait attention en termes de normes
d'élargir certains couloirs pour que les
fauteuils roulants puisse passer voilà
on a quelques matériels adaptés mais bon
voilà c'est déboule avec des picots des
choses qu'on peut adapter également pour
des enfants valides la vie en
collectivité possible aussi bien pour
les enfants valides que porteurs de
handicap elle est source de richesse
pour tout le monde donc voilà c'est le
challenge qu'on veut montrer ici et
c'était au micro de yolaine 13 et deux
williams elle changer notre mode de
consommation d'énergie en se servant
d'une énergie propre est gratuite c'est
ce que fait depuis trois ans cette auto
entrepreneurs de fontenay le fleury en
commercialisant une lampe solaire qu'il
a par ailleurs lui même conçu ce système
permet de s'éclairer en utilisant
l'énergie produite par le soleil mais
surtout de stocker cette énergie pour
s'en servir toute la journée comme nous
l'expliquent william bell à première vue
cette lampe solaire n'a rien
d'exceptionnel la lumière du soleil est
capté par un chargeur photovoltaïque
pour être transformée en énergie mais le
modèle conçu par habib hadjal a une
particularité la lampe est légère et la
lampe ne dépend pas de gros stocks
d'énergie et on utilise quand on voit où
on veut la lampe peut ainsi éclairé pour
une durée moyenne de 7 heures pendant ce
temps l'énergie solaire continue d'être
stockées par le panneau totalement
indépendant je peux en même temps chargé
ma torche en même temps d'accord je suis
charge c'est branché dessus je peux
aussi chargé un téléphone portable vous
utilisez quelque chose qui est à portée
de tout le monde et en même temps vous
utilisez niveau pour le moment à biya de
joie levant ses lampes à des
particuliers un peu partout en france
mais souhaite commercialiser son produit
à l'international il vise le marché
africain
il ya des pays où il n'y a que 2 % de la
population rurale qui a une lettre citée
ces personnes-là utilise la lampe à
pétrole
donc ils sont dépendants du pétrole le
souhait d'abia jo à remplacer l'énergie
fossile par une énergie renouvelable
pour cela il faudra d'abord faire face
aux problèmes de cou à la vente
la lampe est vendu 90 euros un prix bien
trop important pour le continent
africain
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qui viendront
que d'accueillir la première
mission du twenty fort la street culture
à l'honneur durant 24 heures ce week-end
des artistes internationaux du xzibit à
tmx était sur scène des stages de danse
avec les twins ou encore l'or pour
seulement étaient proposés les queens
originaire de banlieue parisienne et qui
était il ya encore quelques jours avec
jay-z et beyoncé au stade de france
des têtes d'affiché mais le public n'a
pas forcément été au rendez vous c'est
une petite déception donc pour les
organisateurs comme moi je pense que
fait pas d'omelette sans casser deux
donc forcément il y a une petite
déception on aurait aimé remplir du
premier coup mais bon un jour et du coup
on a quand même pas mal de monde
un beau public un public qui participe
on a vu avec la danse tout à l'heure
quoi qu'on a voulu casser le modèle en
fait actuel français plutôt rejoindre le
modèle américain en allemagne en
angleterre ce genre de festival la qui
voit souvent le jour c'est un modèle
qu'on a à coeur de reproduire ici sur la
durée justement que nous introduit donc
on est toujours en phase là dessus et
rendez vous dès mercredi pour une
édition spéciale de kiosques le magazine
de la culture qui reviendra très
largement sur le twenty four avec
d'autres interviews des extraits aussi
ce sera à partir de 18h30 et pour
patienter voici quelques images
supplémentaires
non
qui
merci de nous avoir suivi votre soirée
sur téléphiles c'est notamment avec
anthony rech pour une nouvelle édition
du 7 8 sport à demain pour un nouveau
journal